,
DID NOT SERVE ANYTHING IN THOSE
MEETINGS THAT WOULD AFFECT HIM?
SHOOT ME NOW IS MIRANDA DEVINE
FOX'S CONTRIBUTOR AND AUTHOR OF
LAPTOP PRESIDENT PINPOINT USA
AND AUTHOR OF THE COLLEGE SCAM.
NOW MIRANDA THIS IS REALLY ONE
OF MOST SHAMEFUL FLUFF JOBS I
CAN REMEMBER I'VE SEEN A LOT OF
MY DAY WAS SET OUT TO YOU?
>> WELL I GUESS I'M A LITTLE
BIASED BUT THE HUNTER BIDEN
QUESTION WAS JUST EXTRAORDINARY
KNOW TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ASK JOE BIDEN FINALLY IN PERSON
ABOUT ALL THE REVELATIONS OF THE
PAST TWO YEARS ABOUT HIS SON
HUNTER'S BUSINESS DEALINGS BUT
HE ASSURED US BEFORE THE
ELECTION HE KNEW NOTHING ABOUT
IT JUST AN ACCEPTANCE AN
OUTRIGHT LIE IN HIS OWN WORDS
JOE BIDEN SAYS NEVER OBSERVED
ANYTHING ELLEN TOWARD, BUT HE
TOLD US HE DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING
ABOUT THE BUSINESS DEALINGS OR
HOW WOULD HE KNOW WHAT YOU
OBSERVE?
OR WHAT NOT TO OBSERVE.
IT WAS RIDICULOUS AND REALLY
JUST AN EMBARRASSMENT TO THE
STUDENTS AND CBS.
>> Laura: CHARLIE ON THE TERMS
OF DRAMATIC AFTERMATH OF GREAT
MARTHA'S VINEYARD AIRLIFT IF YOU
BOTH BEAR WITH ME FOR A MINUTE
ON AND TO GET THROUGH THIS IT'S
FOR AN EMOTIONAL DAY BECAUSE THE
QUEEN, BUT ALSO THIS.
TO FULLY APPRECIATE THE MOTION I
NEED TO READ THROUGH CNN'S
UNVIABLE REPORTING.
MIGRANTS 44 OUR VISIT LEAVES AN
INDELIBLE MARK ON MARTHA'S
VINEYARD.
ONE VOLUNTEER SAYING WE'RE USED
TO DEALING WITH PEOPLE IN NEED
WE ARE SUPER HAPPY THAT THEY
ENRICHED US.
WE ARE HAPPY TO HELP THEM ON
THEIR JOURNEY.
BYSTANDER TALKS THE MAGNETS A
BAG OF CHOCOLATES AS THEY WERE
LEAVING.
I BROUGHT THE CANDY THEY PROUDLY
BOASTED.
BOSS IMMIGRATION ATTORNEY WHO
GOT THEIR BACKS AND YOU'RE NOT
ALONE.
AND FINALLY A CHURCH ORGANIST
SAID THE ISLAND NOW FELT LONELY.
THE GOVERNOR OF FLORIDA GOT IT
WRONG, THEY THOUGHT THAT WE
WOULDN'T KNOW WHAT THE DEAL,
ACTUALLY PEOPLE HERE REALLY GIVE
A DAMN.
THEY REALLY CARE.
CHARLIE, ACTUALLY THOUGHT THIS
WAS A HEADLINE FROM THE BABYLON
BE OR THE ONION, THIS WAS A 44
OUR OUTPOURING OF SUPPORT FOR
THE MIGRANTS AND YOU MIGHT AS
WELL THOUGHT YOU'RE LIKE DOZENS
OF ORGAN DONATIONS OR SOMETHING
GOING ON AND PEOPLE BEING
INVITED TO STAY FOR A COUPLE OF
MONTHS.
DOUBTS ABOUT THIS BUT AT LEAST
THEY GOT CHOCOLATES RIGHT?
>> LOOK EXPOSE EXACTLY HOW THE
DEMOCRATS ARE ALL FOR THESE
IDEOLOGICAL IDEAS IN THESE
DISTANT PURSUITS UNTIL IT
ACTUALLY AFFECTS THEM THEIR OPEN
BORDERS AS LONG AS THEY CAN STAY
IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD.
ALL FOR SENDING THEIR KIDS TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL, BUT NOT YOUR
KIDS.
THEY WANT YOU TO WITH THE FAMILY
GOVERNMENT SCHOOL.
DOES THE WAY THAT THE LEFT IS
ALWAYS OPERATED SOMETIMES THEY
SAY IT'S HYPOCRISY, THE
HIERARCHY AND THE WAY TO GET THE
DEMOCRATS ATTENTION THE HIGH
SELVES GOVERNMENT IS NOT TO SEND
THEM TO KAMALA HARRIS AND NOT TO
CHICAGO, AND ASCEND ONTO THE
HOMES OF DEMOCRAT DONORS.
THEY START TO FREAK OUT I WAS SO
AMAZING THAT WE CARE SO DEEPLY
ABOUT THESE MIGRANTS, ALL WE
CARE SO DEEPLY ABOUT THEM THAT
YOU KICK THEM OFF YOUR ISLAND
AND WHAT 44 HOURS?
WE ALWAYS ENRICH THE EXPERIENCE,
THE ENRICHED EXPERIENCE SO MUCH
THEY COULDN'T EVEN KEEP THEM
THERE FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS.
YOU KNOW WHO DOESN'T HAVE THE
LUXURY QUESTION AT THE BORDER
TOWNS IN ARIZONA.
THE BORDER TOWNS IN TEXAS DON'T
HAVE THE LUXURY JUST TO KICK
THEM OFF THE MAINLAND, 5,000 A
DAY.
I APPLAUD GOVERNOR DeSANTIS
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP AND QUITE
HONESTLY EXPOSING HOW THE
DEMOCRATS TRULY DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE PEOPLE THEY CLAIM TO
SUPPORT.
>> Laura: MIRANDA HEADED TO A
CONFESSION CONFESSION ON FRIDAY
I THINK WAS FRIDAY I SAID I
SPENT MY BIG VACATION THIS
SUMMER IN MARTHA'S VINEYARD
OKAY, CRUCIFY ME.
AND OF THE ISLAND WELL I KNOW
THE ISLAND WELL.
SO I LOVE SEEING ALL THIS
CONCERN I DON'T HAVE THE
RESOURCES FOR THE MIGRANTS
RIGHT?
THIS JUST ONE OF MY MANY PHOTOS
THAT I'VE TAKEN IS COURTESY OF A
FRIEND OF MINE.
THIS IS PRETTY CLOSE TO WHERE
THE OBAMA'S LIVE RIGHT?
IT'S A BIT OF A PIECE OF LAND IT
WAS USED MOSTLY FOR AGRICULTURE,
BUT THERE'S A LOT OF LAND THERE.
YOU COULD PITCH TENTS, YOU CAN'T
HAVE MOBILE HOMES IS AGAINST THE
LAW THERE.
YOU HAVE TENSE AND NICE MOBILE
TENTS AND IT'S THE OFF-SEASON.
THERE IS PLENTY OF ROOM IN
MARTHA'S VINEYARD MIRANDA THEY
KNEW HOW TO ENFORCE THEIR
BORDERS WHEN THEY WANTED TO DO A
WHOLE DEPORTATION DEAL.
>> THEY SURE DID AND LOOK IN
THIS PRESIDENT OBAMA'S HOUSE I
THINK IS EIGHT BEDROOMS AND ONLY
FOUR PEOPLE IN THE FAMILY,
THERE'S AMPLE ROOM TO BE ONE OF
THE BILLIONAIRES FOR MARTHA'S
VINEYARD VERY DAVID.
EXACTLY, THEIR COMPASSION SEWING
THEORETICAL YOU HEARD IT THERE
WHILE THE MIGRANTS FROM THE
ISLAND THEY WERE FREAKING OUT
BUT AS SOON AS THEY DEPORTED
THEM TO SOME MILITARY BASE IN
CAPE COD THAT WAS WHEN THEY WERE
LYRICAL.
>> Laura: I LOVE IT, THEY'VE
CHANGED US, THEY CHANGED US.
IT'S LIKE THE BACHELOR WHEN THEY
SET I FELL IN LOVE, WE WERE IN
LOVE, HE WAS KISSING 12 GIRLS AT
NIGHT OKAY?